attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonges bien nous sommes réunis pour
fêter le départ de fabrice non c'est
francis et parce qu'en fait j'ai pas osé
vous reprendre le premier jour quand je
suis arrivée dans la boîte et puis bah
après l'engrenage que non je suis désolé
on va rester sur fabrice ça fait des
années qu'on vous appelle fabrice on va
pas changer pour les dix dernières
minutes patron manier vous le cul on a
tous envie de picoler l'un donc fabrice
était un pilier de l'entreprise
il a effectué un travail remarquable
ressources humaines annonce et aux
services généraux non et au marketing et
non j'étais à la compta bref il était
partout et surtout la cantine qu'aucun
bon allez on peut traquer entre connaît
bien la nadine quand c'est gratos n'est
pas la dernière
d'ailleurs celle qui voit les ramettes
de papier le feu à oui c'est pour mes
enfants je vais quand même pas payer
pour qu'il me fasse des dessins moche
bref fabrice nous quittent pour réaliser
ses projets personnels
mes projets personnels c'est le pôle
emploi on m'avait viré
bon j'ai fait mon petit discours je vais
quand même pas rester pour boire du
mousseux dans des gobelets en plastique
jeukens salue les pauvres donc pour toi
bien si on a décidé de faire un petit
cadeau et on s'est presque tous cotisés
moi j'ai rien donné parce que je t'aime
pas trop ça c'est la grosse pince on le
sait est un grand amateur de football
moi c'est le rugby voilà le sport du
coup on t'a fait un petit maillot
personnalisé avec le chiffre 3 qui
correspond évidemment au nombre d'années
que tu as passé d'entreprise ça suffit
temps que lui dans la boîte contient
rien tiens tu rajoutes debout se fait à
huit femmes dont la claque pour sabri a
au tube emerton tous au buffet les deux
hommes buffet
[Musique]